[Music]
a few things about tonight one is that
this is basically our second anniversary
here at the interval and it started with
another book event by another Wired
editor Adam Rogers when he launched his
book proof you can see we didn't quite
have our chalkboard robot yet we didn't
even have our shelves for all the booths
yet so we were kind of a pre opening for
that but it's it's great that we've made
it to year 2 as you know we kind of
started the interval as a nonprofit to
really have a different model of
interacting with all people like you
that we didn't want to have the only
model of a non-profit B to have our
hands out and asking for a donation but
more to have a transactional model
that's more like a business and it is a
business and it's thriving which has
been really great thanks to all of you
as you know we raise the ticket prices
for tonight for the general group as
well as the patron tickets so thank you
all for getting those tickets that's to
support this series overall throughout
the year we don't operate this series at
a profit but the rest of the thing does
work at a profit so this is how we're
kind of balancing that out so thank you
very much
a couple other announcements we do have
a livestream for all of our members of
these talks that's sponsored by ed
Burtynsky one of our previous speakers
in his new movie anthropo scene and then
we're for the first time I'm announcing
that we're going to start to podcast and
do video of this series with a grant
from the Elks Family Foundation so we'll
start to see some of those coming out so
we're gonna get at least 12 to 14 coming
out later this year which were excited
about so yeah so it's June 7th it's a
when we opened the bar two years ago
June 6th is when Stuart brand
incorporated long now 20 years ago
yesterday so it's our 20th birthday also
so yeah so a few birthdays and just so
you know the next talk we have coming up
as Andrew signal who's also in the
audience from casbahs and I think that's
most of our announcements the the format
of the talk tonight is going to be a
little bit different as many of you know
Kevin's also speaking in the series that
Stuart brand hosts at it'll be at the
herps Theatre 900 people be a little bit
different feeling than the the talk
you're about to get with 60 people and
so he's going to do a shortened version
of the talk and then make it much more
interactive we're gonna have two mics so
we can really move that around and so
the goal is to really make the second
half of the talk one where you're
getting some some questions in and and
we really make it into a conversation
and then his book the inevitable as I
said just came out today literally and
so you can get it and then after the
talk he'll be signing them up here at
the podium you can buy them in the back
right there with that are one of our
founding board members kevin kelly thank
you so as to repeat what Xander said I
am really very privileged and honored
that people have decided to contribute
to this series by paying a little bit
extra for the tickets thank you for
coming out and doing that a lot of
familiar faces many faces I haven't seen
and also to repeat what Xander said
because I'll be talking at this same
subject a little bit at length I decided
to try and do a very kind of blitz
version of one of the trends and then
I'm going to do something experimental
so what I will do for the other part of
it is actually I have a list of
questions that I don't know the answers
to so the book is really stuff that I'm
sure about so I have a bunch of things
that I've don't know what my answers are
and I'm gonna actually kind of have you
help me answer them I'd like to hear
what your answers are no talking to
given my my side of it and we can think
out loud so this is the most of this
talk will be about things that I'm not
sure about the first part of it is stuff
that I'm sure
about so that's the format and I thought
this would be a little bit more
conducive to this group here this venue
we can interact I want to hear what you
have to say about some of these ideas
and I'll still be enough of me in it so
what I want to do then is kind of give
you let's see which one am I going this
way yeah a version of one of the trends
that I'm thinking about the one actually
I think it's the most important which is
you'll see this is cognate I but the
general title inevitable is used in a
soft way I mean it in a kind of a soft
way that there is baked into the very
physics of the materials transistors
wires batteries the whole the whole
thing that that it tends to lean in
certain directions and that that leaning
is something that we can actually
discern and therefore say it's going to
lean in this direction and that is where
it's going and that's the way I use
inevitable that there that these things
that this bias is built-in and I'm
trying to identify the bias okay and so
electrical wires waves these all produce
recurring effects and that these
recurring effects for me are most
visible in the ways in which technology
are used and unofficially the way that
they aren't supposed to be used the way
that they are abused the way that the
street uses them to you bill bill
Gibson's terms so that's where I like to
pay attention to is how people are using
this technology in the ways that wasn't
supposed to be used because I think we
get a better sense of where this bias is
going to and if we could identify the
bias that's what the technology wants us
inherent direction that it's going
so the long term trends I think you're
actually predictable in that sense of we
can see where they have been going and
they will tend to go in that direction
but the specifics are not at all
predictable so the genres are the
species are not so an example would be
the quadruped ed form is kind of
inevitable there's going to be then
because that's the form and
life there's many many forms of
quadrupeds those are predictable but the
zebra is not okay
and so in the same sense you could say
telephones are inevitable if you make
wires electricity you're gonna make a
telephone system but the iPhone is not
predictable it's completely contingent
the internet was inevitable but Twitter
was not the Internet was inevitable but
the kind of Internet that we could make
or want to make we have a choice in
whether it's international national
commercial or non-commercial those are
all choices that we had they make a lot
of difference to us and they are not
inevitable so I'm talking about the
larger scale trends the the the more of
the biases built into this that are
leaning in certain directions and those
directions I think are important because
they are the main drivers and we can
expect them and we can prepare for them
and they are going to do the large-scale
genre forms so I have 12 trends in this
book but they're basically umbrella
categories to put lots of things under
of them so they're not necessarily there
they're somewhat arbitrary but there
there are groupings and they all by the
way our verbs are jaren's because I
think one of the moves that we're seeing
is this move from physical nouns to
verbs to things that are always in
process to this liquid world that's one
of the trends so I think in terms of of
these verbs and I'm going to take one of
them um there are others like tracking
so let me just say it very simply that
we're moving to a world where there's
more and more tracking we're tracking
ourselves with fitbit's
quantified self we're tracking each
other's when we take a photograph and
tag it of our friends companies are
tracking us the government's are
tracking us I'd see nothing in the near
future of 25 years where there's less
tracking there's going to be more of it
because the Internet is a tracking
machine and one
to track in it anything that can be
tracked it touches it will be tracked so
there's that kind of a thing I'm not
going to talk more about that but
they're sharing the same ways there's
this flowing of streams of things rather
than fixed entities the thing I want to
talk about in this brief intro is
cognate I is making things smarter I use
this word obscure word because smarta
fie smarting there's no we don't have a
good verb for making things smarter but
that's what we're doing we're we're
taking everything and we're making it
smarter and we're taking making some
dumb things a little smart and we're
taking some smart things and making them
much smarter that process is ongoing and
if you make a transistor if you make a
logic gate once you have that you
wouldn't have never we make things
smarter and smarter and smarter so we're
moving in the direction where this AI
stuff is coming and we don't really have
much choice if we keep making technology
about it getting smarter and smarter but
we do have a lot of choice about how we
make it smart and you know what we do
with it there's specifics so I think AI
is once is it's pretty inevitable once
you've made these kinds of things and
the proof of course is that it's already
here I mean that's the thing is is that
AI is diagnosed x-rays much better than
humans dude they go through legal
evidence much better than a human
paranoia lawyer would do they if you're
flying on a flight commercially the
pilot human pilots are flying seven to
eight minutes the AI is doing the rest
of it and your little chips and your
brakes brake much better than than you
do and that's why the eye is in the
brake of your cars so of course
alphago from goggle recently beat the
world go master we all see that that's
now that's happening it's done but some
interesting stuff as Google actually has
the same AI that they
how to they taught it to learn how to
play a videogame they teaching it to
play a videogame was trivial but they
taught it to how to learn to play the
video games so they just showed it a
video game and it's on the screen and
that learned how to play the video game
by trial and error and within a day of
playing all the time it could be a human
so it didn't know how to play didn't
know anything about the rules it was
just watching playing the game just as
much as you would so this kind of
artificial learning is very important
but the thing about AI is that we have
this vocabulary challenge which is that
whenever we accomplish something we no
longer call it AI once it can do
something was called machine learning or
something or algorithmic stuff so AI is
basically defined as that which we can't
do so it's always receding into the
future so AI is you know stuff that we
can't do that want to do and once we can
do it it's no longer AI it's obvious
it's trivial it's this machine
algorithmic stuff it's not a odd so part
of what talking about it becomes
difficult is is is that there there is
this definitional challenge so I think
there are three reasons why AI is worth
paying attention to right now and the
first one has to do with the fact that
our own intelligence has a very
incomplete and inaccurate assessment of
what it is all right we don't know it
what intelligence is basically but the
one thing I'm pretty sure about is is
that IQ is not a single vector it's not
a single dimension although we tend to
think of it as if we held IQ there's the
rat and the mouse and the chimp and then
there's a really dumb person and then
there's us me and then there's Einstein
and then there's a super thing it's all
it's like it's like louder it's like a
sound that gets louder and louder and
that's what we think of normally but
that's totally totally wrong what AI is
much more like what intelligence excuse
me is much more like is a kind of a
symphony of different notes played on
different instrument
in each of those instruments is a
different kind of cognition so we have
this society of mine we have this sort
of symphony of many different kinds of
thinking's cognitive reasoning deduction
spatial navigation memory there's
there's there's we don't even know maybe
hundreds of different types of thinking
that are aggregated into what we call
intelligence and we generally think of
human intelligence as general-purpose
but it's absolutely not general-purpose
it's specifically to our species for our
evolution and we'll see as we make on
the currents that it's just will have
the same kapor nyan overthrow that we
had with the idea that we're at the
center of the solar system and we
realize we're in the corner we're gonna
say the same thing as we inhabit or fill
out the the the space of possible
intelligences will see that our
intelligence is just in a corner it's
this one very very specific kind of
intelligence made up of this this basket
of different kinds of thinking but the
thing about intelligence is that animals
have a another basket of them and some
of their instruments are the same as
ours the same the same kind of thinking
but in some cases they're actually
superior or exceeding ours so the rat
may have in a superior intelligence for
spatial navigation or the the monkey may
have even higher level of social
intelligence and so that they're higher
in some and they'll be lower inferior in
others but this is a completely
different basket it's a different kind
of thinking and likewise with the AI
that we're going to make the machines
were some will engineer that so that
some of them are much superior to us in
that instrument much louder than ours
and the point I want to make is that
that is why we're going to make those
AIS is because they exceed us in these
other dimensions they can think
differently from us and that's what we
want so we have this artificial
smartness which I like to use more than
artificial intelligence because
smartness takes away some of that
baggage that we have associated with
intelligence these are all different
ways of being smart and
your calculator today is already smarter
than you are in arithmetic but we're not
freaked out by that because it's very
narrow it's very specific and your GPS
is much smaller than you in spatial
navigation in Google it's much smarter
than you and recall and so these are all
these artificial types of smartness and
we're going to enjoy engineer much more
complicated and complex baskets salads
are these kinds of intelligences and as
they become broader they will become
more robust but they will never really
be general-purpose because I mean we'll
have Swiss Army knives versions but they
will be like a Swiss Army knife they
will be very very timid in broad but not
very deep in any one thing so again the
point of making these artificial minds
is that they don't think like humans and
therefore when you put them into the car
they don't drive like humans the reason
why we want the auto driven cars is
because they are driving like us they
it's their non human and the fact that
they don't have a consciousness is
actually a feature so we're gonna
advertise them as being conscious free
because they aren't worried about
whether they should have majored in
finance or whether they have left the
stove on or whatever they are focused on
driving they're really optimized to have
that intelligence that road intelligence
who may want to call it so that sense of
making these non-human like
intelligences is sort of what we're
doing there there is this kind of space
of possible Minds that we are unaware of
right now except maybe in the animal
kingdom and even that we don't have any
kind of measurements for different kinds
of animal minds but we should but we're
gonna we're gonna again inhabit the
possibility space of intelligence by
making all these artificial minds and
there are all different kinds of
thinking they're all different species
of thinking so I would like to think of
it while we have all species among the
animal kingdom we have all Minds all
kinds of all species of minds that are
before us and our job is sort of in in a
kind of a cosmic sense is to
make or discover these kinds of minds
that biology probably couldn't get to by
itself so we're the the kinds of minds
that that tissue can make DNA can make
are limited but we're going to actually
through us populate all the other kinds
of thinking that you could do that the
biology alone could not get to so
there's lots of very different kinds of
minds and I think that some of the most
tracked intractable mysterious questions
we have say about dark energy quantum
gravity we may need these alternative
kinds of minds to work with us to solve
them so human intelligence alone may not
be sufficient to solve them we are our
first job is kind of a two-step thing is
to invent these other kinds of thinking
to help us work with us to solve these
problems and we see some of that kind of
evidence right now in doing computer
proofs for mathematics where we actually
don't even understand the proof we just
rely on the fact that there is this mind
that says yeah that's right and so we'll
be making other kinds of Minds like this
and so as I said they may be needed for
solving some of our hardest problems I'd
like to think of these things as alien
intelligences maybe think of these as
kind of artificial aliens because they
will be thinking differently than us and
they will have some of the attributes of
actually contacting et even beyond just
to be able to think and have that
practical reason I think also they will
have other attributes that we might
associate with higher levels of
intelligence like say consciousness or
self reflection and so they might give
us much of the same kind of high that we
would have by having contact with an
alien intelligence which who knows if it
will happen but it's very certain that
we will make them here on earth so
that's one thing this idea of making
different kinds of thinking and that's
the feature of them that's the reason
why we want to make them so the second
idea is is that I think we really are
kind of involved in a second
revolution that's one of the term so you
remember the first Industrial Revolution
was primarily about artificial power so
instead of everything being built in the
world with human muscle or animal muscle
we invented this thing called artificial
power which was primarily fueled by
fossil fuels or carbon fuels like wood
and through that system we could do all
these amazing things and basically the
entire prosperity that we see around us
now today is feeding off of the fact
that we had this we harnessed these
artificial powers and so when you're
going down the highway you have 250
horses that you're using at the command
of this little switch and there are 250
horses sending you down the highway and
so that's automated power and that's and
we took that same kind of automated
synthetic power and we put it into a
grid electrical grid and send it out to
after the whole country and other
countries later and that distributed
power artificial power was again the
foundation of the automation of
factories of homesteads of farms and
anybody anywhere could plug into that
you could purchase this artificial power
you even have to generate it yourself
you could just buy as much as you wanted
to and do what you wanted with it and
you could even be innovative and you
could take something like a a hand pump
they took muscle and you could say hey
I'm gonna take some of that artificial
power and I'm gonna add the power and
I'm gonna get a electrical pump and that
was this the source of a lot of the
wealth and generate and innovation in
fact what was curious about it was in
the beginning companies had the vp's of
electricity there was somebody in charge
because this is a complicated stuff it
was it was it was new unknown it was
messy nobody knew how to work so you had
your VP of electricity who's in charge
of electrifying the company ok and so
now what we're doing is we're taking
those electrical things and we're adding
artificial intelligence artificial
smartness and we're making the smart
pumps ok ok and the the thing about it
is is in the same way
we're gonna get that from a grid you're
not gonna have to generate that aaaah
yourself you're just going to purchase
it as much as you want from this cloud
grid
it'll be like electricity will be
available you buy as much a as you want
or can afford and so this thing will
basically instead of having in addition
to having 250 horses in your car you'll
now have 250 mines as well and that's
the auto driven car that's the smart car
that's the driverless car so we'll now
have all that kind of artificial power
and that same thing that we did with
cars we're just going to do with
everything else so every so I would say
that everything we've electrified we're
not going to cognate I okay and and and
the consequences of that will be equal
and exceed the first Industrial
Revolution in terms of what is unleashes
because just as I can go there and I can
get 250 horsepower or a thousand people
worth of energy and muscle whatever will
now go and get a thousand people worth
of brains to do whatever it is we want
to waste it on because that's that's
where the real innovation happens is
when you waste it okay so my formula for
the next 10,000 startups is very easy
take X whatever X is a day I find
something and add AI to it that you buy
that you get off the grid that's just
you purchase but if AI is a commodity as
I'm suggesting then you can also reverse
it and say something like well you take
a yeah you have to add X to it just like
you you know if you take a come on to
the water everybody has you have to add
something special to a story and
interface something to make it different
because this is a commodity so it works
both ways so but this is combination of
X plus AI and here's the thing
this is a Google which is actually a
Google service but this is an example of
somebody where you can actually query
the AI and ask these questions like what
color is the ground what color is the
ball and it's telling you I mean it
understands it sees the picture is
giving you back you can buy that service
from Google today right now
for six cents a hundred hits so if it's
it's available now today as a cloud
service you can just buy your AI and
that's the second thing so it's it's a
commodity you'll be able to purchase in
anybody who wants to okay so the third
thing that is it's worth thinking about
AI right now is that when we put the AI
into a body we call that a robot this is
a kind of robot from Rodney Brooks at
MIT who's now with iRobot and Heartland
I think it's called
rethink robots and the idea is is that
this one instead of being it's an
industrial robot but instead of being
one that you have to program you
actually show it what you want it to do
and it's watching what you do and so it
can work with people who are illiterate
it can work right next to people because
it's also aware of its surroundings
unlike most industrial robots and so
it's a car called a personal robot in
the same sense of personal computer
meaning that you don't need a priesthood
of people to service it anybody can buy
it and you can put it in your garage
okay and so the reason what we're gonna
use these for the robots and the
automation is anything that can be
specified in terms of productivity or
efficiency next includes physical work
we call their work as well as most of
white-collar work if you have something
a task that can be specified in terms of
efficiency or productivity it's going to
go to the bots
okay so productivity is for BOTS it's
not for humans what humans are really
good at I'm just kind of joking earlier
is wasting time okay I'm in efficiency
so most of our jobs are a bunch of tasks
and some of those tasks will go to the
BOTS and the other aspects of them will
just be changed and so our tasks will
more and more revolve around the stuff
there are inefficient so what's in it
well I mean science isn't Hera lis
inefficient you you're not going to do
experiments that you know that work if
you if science was efficient you would
just do the same experiment over and
over again because you know it worked as
soon as you start to do experiments that
fail which is the main instrument of
learning
you're inefficient innovation is
inherently inefficient because you're
just making sakes to try and stuff it
doesn't work that's not efficient it's
incredibly inefficient the same thing
with the human experiences which are not
very efficient by definition so all
these things and art are the kinds of
things are the current their aspects the
tasks that we are good at and will be
for a long while
while the Box are really good at things
that we can specify and/or care about in
terms of productivity so the last thing
is is is the the real driver I think is
actually this idea of a center which
came out of Gary Kasparov the IBM chess
champion who lost I mean that chess
champion who lost to IBM deep blue and
he complained about the fact that deep
blue had access to a complete database
of every single chess move ever made he
said if I had access to the same
database
I could have beat deep blue so he made
up a new chess league a kind of a
freestyle where you could play as a
human an AI or a cent or AI plus human
and for the last three or four years the
best chess player in the world is not an
AI and it's not a human chess master
it's a center it's a team of AI plus
human and that's true for the best
diagonally diagnostic it's not a a AI
and it's not a doctor it's a doctor plus
AI and so that idea of working with
machines of having them complement our
type of thinking with their type of
thinking is actually where we're going
so I believe that you will be paid in
the future by how well you work with
these AIS okay so they're not we're not
working against and we're gonna be
working with them because they think
differently and if you can actually if
you can be the horse whisperer you can
be the AI Whisperer and understand then
do you have an advantage in terms of
being able to to be the best in your
class so we'll work with them not
against them so I I just want to end
with a generic call to the future which
is that by the way there no AI experts
right there are a lot of people who are
working in AI right now there's a ton of
money going into it but in terms of long
view there are no experts we don't need
we have no idea really we're just at the
beginning at the beginning okay so the
greatest invention would today some
people might say was the web did not
exist 25 years ago okay if I was giving
this talk 25 years ago I wouldn't have
mentioned the web because they hadn't
been invented yet
so I think in 25 years from now it's
very likely that the major thing there
is probably not AI but something that
hasn't been invented yet today it's
almost statistically probable okay so
we're at the beginning of the beginning
of the beginning of the beginning worth
our 1 and that means that you're not
late
[Laughter]
so that's what I know now I want to talk
about what I don't know okay and what I
have actually is I have a list of
questions that I don't know the answers
to that I would like to know the answers
to that I'm not sure about that may have
some ideas about but I just don't know
and so what I thought I would do is read
a question and then if somebody has an
answer I'll take one I'll take one
suggested answer and then we'll talk
about it I'll add some things to it then
we move on to the other one so so this
is experiment it could fail can I say
just to keep it brief keep it very very
brief and I'll cut you off no hesitation
and so again these are things that I'm
kind of turning over my own line
struggling with and whatnot so I'll
start the first one has to do with AI
and as you could see I'm very
enthusiastic about it and very very
positive about it but here's something I
do struggle with is I wonder if we are
going to be comfortable with treating
robots like slaves even if they aren't
whether whether that's the kind of
corrosive stance to have with them and
if you've seen the Boston Dynamics of
the guys and people kicking those things
and we cringe that suggests I mean we
may not be so even though we have all
these things and they're doing all the
stuff it's like what is how are we going
to feel about that and I'm of two minds
one of this this machines will get used
to it and we won't cry when we turn them
off and the other one is no we're just
we're going to we're gonna really have
to have a whole different set of ethics
and and we'll educate ourselves to treat
them differently
and I and right now I don't know myself
so I see it I'm gonna look at the person
who has her hand up before I even finish
that one okay yeah so this is this is
purely anecdotal but it has to do with
Boston Dynamics so
down at Fort Bragg they took big dog out
with a platoon to test how the guys are
going to use it in the field and the
guys kept protecting their big dog and
putting themselves in harm's way because
it was a team member and it wasn't
beating up on where you go through
sucker it was all looking after their
robot and this is also seen in the field
in Iraq when they sent in bond and
disposed of groups with iRobot the guys
won't work with a new replacement bot
they will wait for that one to be at
least 50% of it when comes back because
it's part of their guys so it's
interesting to see that the initial
usage for these things we're not being
mean we're being very careful that's
fabulous thank you I love that so I take
one more question answer answer excuse
me so then if you could come over here
somebody young so I think possibly a
more apt comparison that feels to me is
rather than slaves pets is how we treat
pets looking at the already emergent
robot pets and the story you're saying
that humans don't see pets as equal but
they're still very willing to make great
sacrifices and feel deep deep emotional
attachments to their pets just one more
comment on this it's not just pets it's
our use of language so as soon as Alexa
came into our household I started saying
things to Stuart like Stuart would you
get that you know you know and or Stuart
tell Alexa and I we started saying
please Alexa and thank you and thank you
Alexa because he was changing our actual
dynamic of how we talk to each other so
this is fast I think so okay so alright
that's that's good I'm gonna well maybe
we'll come back to it because I think
there's a lot to say and it's hard for
me to kind of extrapolate to see which
way I even I would go because I don't I
don't know and and also I think we can
change our minds too
collectively wisss with this experience
so pets is a good analogy besides slaves
but we maybe will have slaves and pets
okay that's that's possible that there's
different categories and it is
interesting that if those quadrupeds
boston dynamics were a different shape
we would definitely feel differently
about him if they had wheels okay with
that and we were just Dana and I were
talking about I was just attended the
first self-driving car race okay so have
self-driving car racing and the thing
about it is that you'll kind of look
forward to them crashing because there's
you know you know there's nobody inside
and so we kind of like to see machines
destroying each other and kind of away
if they have wheels but if they were
kind of like animals shape would we feel
that comfortable so this may be
something where there's all kind of the
signifiers and just the whether they
have legs or don't it's kind of strange
so maybe we can we might educate
ourselves to decide that legs don't
really matter so another question that I
had was what are the the I talk about
total tracking and in this book a lot
and the fact that I think everything I
look at suggests that that that we will
have thousands or hundreds of more time
more tracking than we have right now and
and that we won't be able to stop it let
me just give you the the analogy so so I
I think there's inherent propensity in
in the kind of technology to to copy
things that's the way things get across
the internet is they're being copied all
along the ways and so it's kind of built
and has a bias to copy stuff and so
either way I would describe it is that
the Internet is the world's largest copy
machine and anything that could possibly
be copied if it touches it it's get
copied so if you have a movie music a
book and it touches the internet it will
be copied and discriminately and flow or
cross everywhere and they got kind of a
soup
distribution liquid and and so trying to
so that the music industry for 20 years
tried to work against that bias they
were trying to go up against the grain
of this thing which is wanted to copy
and they wanted to prohibit copy copy
protection digital rights management
sued the customer who's copying a lot
and it didn't work for two decades and
they tried to try to gradually they're
coming around to accepting the fact that
they can't stop the copying if that work
with a copying that's the only way to do
it and I would make the same analogy
that the internet is to the world's
largest tracking machine and anything
that can be tracked if it touches the
internet will be tracked and and you
can't stop the tracking you can kind of
fight against it prohibit it you can do
with the music industry did is like we
want less of it we won't allow it will
legislate it but it's going to be at
odds with the general bias in this
technology to track everything and and
by the way I'm really I wrote this big
article about VR for Wired I'm also
think that that's coming very fast if
when you are in a VR world you're
basically in a total surveillance world
every thing is inherently being tracked
all your movements and that when we have
the backward facing cameras that will
record your micro-expressions so your
avatar will be you and you will know a
little bit what frightens you where you
are how you do and there's you spend
more time this will become a huge amount
of data so you'll be able to be tracked
there and in ways you could do it in
real life very expensively it'll be
cheap and ubiquitous within VR so VR
will is inherently more tracking and so
if that's true if if there if there is a
sense in which there is ubiquitous
tracking and we have to work with it
so I'm interested in how we work with it
so one of the ideas in the book I talk
about is covalence a symmetrical
knowledge about you watch the Watchers
you hold them accountable you have some
fit etc which is not inevitable I think
that's one of the ways that we can do it
but it's not inevitable it's it's one
possible way but at the same time I'm
also trying to think about what the
limits are to this is they're actually
hard lines about what we just simply
won't let to be tracked and where that
is and as I examine my own life to say
well what is it
is there something inherently that is
just at the edge and what would that
look like and what does that look like
for other people so what are the actual
limits of transparency in which we
simply as people are not going to accept
because here's the thing we have evolved
until recent times the hundreds of
thousands of years we evolved without
privacy right so in the end in the end
the tribal clan there was the only
privacy had was in your head because
everything else was visible to everybody
else everybody knew what you were doing
and you knew what they were doing and
that was that's how we evolved
biologically so this is not foreign to
us this state of mutual watching is
absolutely how we evolved and so what
was at that time the only only limit was
what you had in your head those those
were private so everything else was
shared so I'm asking myself was that is
that what the limit is is just what's
inside my head or is there something
else so out there okay here's the
question
help me think way in the back somebody
has her hand up way in the back whit's
wait for the microphone so the final
population of the question is what are
the limits to transparency if you if you
believe that basically I'm like how or
where you could say what's the limit to
what's the most what's the most
essential amount of privacy in which you
there's no no negotiating on what's the
minimal maybe some ways
what's the minimal privacy that you
would accept whoops so go ahead yeah I
think it comes down to what we're
willing to pay for and what we're
willing to take for free so if you're
willing to take let's talk about you
yeah what's your limit me uh I I
personally I I'm very open I think
anything I do online I have no limits
how about how about offline offline
honestly like I've given up on my
privacy okay come with in your head I
don't even own blinds on my apartment
how about with in your head would you
mind if we could read your thoughts if
if you could read everyone else's
thoughts and I'd be fine with that okay
okay yeah so okay someone else right in
the middle right there you yeah okay I
think it has a lot to do with what
you're punished for so one of the one of
the problems with transparency even
having run some more transparent
companies is that there that
transparency can be indistinguishable
from public shaming and so I think that
that's something we're gonna have to
reckon with which is that you know when
your thoughts are in your head and not
so many people have access to it right
there are fewer people that you can that
can punish you for your thoughts but as
those things become transparent then you
kind of get you know that problem and I
think Marshall McLuhan kind of said
something about that with the original
formulation of the global village yeah
exactly you know we could actually
though we could actually have
punishments that were much more attuned
to those kinds of private transgressions
so right now we make a big deal about
them but we could certainly tone those
down and say okay you're speeding but
but that is as in fact there was nobody
around so it makes it okay so we
actually have kind of more of a dynamic
sense of the law so that's one way we
could actually work with that in terms
of how we're punished for those
transgressions so I'll take one more
question yes right here
one more answers use me yes jeopardy is
right I have the questions you the
answers just to play off what you just
said within a vr environment are there
morals right are there with that yes so
III think there might be worlds where
that would be something that the person
who made those world might have a have
more say than others maybe you aren't
allowed to do things or maybe you're
punished for doing certain things in a
world that had a moral code so I think
that might go world by world that would
be an interesting I mean we have a kind
of a little bit of that right now with
different online systems that treats a
and then many differently or
transgressions they have different
policies so you could say they have
different moral codes may be kicked off
one faster than another for doing
something so I think worlds would
definitely have that and and and by the
way related to that we're teaching
robots ethics so there's a group in
Stanford and actually Google who's
teaching these dry self-driving cars
ethical rules because when you'd have a
crash or something you could imagine
well does the car turn towards the
divider and harm the driver it the risk
of turning away from the pedestrian so
who gets favored and and we give our
humans we give ourselves a pass because
we don't time to think about it but the
robots actually do have time to think
about and they have to be thought about
before in terms of the program and so in
a certain sense we're really lousy
humans are lousy with ethical we're
inconsistent we're not very advanced
were we don't go very deep with it but
we're actually going to teach these
self-driving robots to be better than us
and I think and eventually they will
kind of come back with they will teach
us to be better ethically by us having
to teach them and so III think that's so
I think there isn't a chance actually in
terms of putting moral codes and ethical
things into these artificial worlds that
we actually have a chance
to actually make ourselves better
because we're pretty lousy in it right
now we think we're really good at it but
we're not yes it's me
it's the microphone guy yeah so I was
just I just saw VR thing that's it's a
European group that put together at the
CAD nonprofit that focuses on that
self-driving car can unde hram and kind
of brings together all the things really
nicely I'll post it to the interval what
along now Twitter but it it questions
should insurance companies should does
the individual be over overruled and and
should they have any say in it if we
could see the costs and human life and
dollars that would happen around it so
the next question is I'm asking myself
is one of the things that posit in this
book is is this kind of really cool kind
of weird situation where where we have
this abundancy and we have more and more
of the world being made into commodity
so the prices go down and down and the
one scarcity which was observed by
Herbert Simon probably 50 years ago was
that the one scarcity in this world of
abundance is human attention which is
limited and it's only we are the same
amount 24 hours and more interestingly
we can't save it up we have to spend it
every day okay we have to spend it in
real time and so this in this kind of a
world of abundance the only scarcity
being human attention it should be the
most valuable thing and yet we're giving
it away free so one of the things I see
is I could see a kind of a coming
disruption in the advertising world
which is the foundation of most of the
big money in the internet companies is
what if we charged for our attention we
charged then we were paid to watch an ad
we were paid to read someone's email
okay so we so that would be very
disruptive to the ad agencies because
what would happen is that the companies
who want attention are going to pay the
customers directly instead of going
through this intermediate which is the
advertising company it's good the
advertising companies pitch was hey we
have attention of these people you don't
so pay us and
we'll get their attention to him so that
was it was mediated but you could go
directly and just pay so to speak the
customers who were influential and we
see that kind of happening right now and
you can kind of get these Klout scores
and say all that she's very influential
and she may have lots of followers and
so we'll give her a free product or
we'll pay her for her attention so the
question I have is I'm asking myself I
don't know the answer to is how much is
my attention worth how much would I
charge so this guy in the front says
won't that be market determined yes so
how much should I charge so the answer
is I don't know but what what do we
think it is what would you start at
what's your what's the first price okay
right here
so the general concept is vrm or vendor
relationship management CRM vendor
relationship management
okay so doc Searls has been working on
this for a decade going if we inverted
the process of having others determine
what the ads delivered to our eyeballs
were work right how would we turn around
and set it so it has to be market based
and as you said it's it's almost a
digital definition of how differentiate
it okay our economic value charge that's
all I want to know how are you going to
charge per ad yeah for your time how
much is your time worth to watch an ad I
probably come off with $200 an hour okay
anyone else have a is that what you're
gonna anyone else to start off cheaper
than that or is that I mean is that to
$2.00 does that just I just charged you
negative $35 for this hour I mean yeah I
paint you this is complicated yeah
exactly it's complicated right so it's
like you're willing to pay but you
wanted to be paid is it just kind of a
wash the else have an answer there's one
guy here and then we'll get you okay so
in the back
yeah so I currently spend $9.99 to not
have Spotify advertise to me okay kind
of inverse that right so you're looking
at how much am I willing to get paid to
have advertising I don't think $200 an
hour is about where I'm at but probably
around like $50 per 30-second spot okay
all right right
so there's there's another gal right
here I want to hear her and then I have
something to say right now right up here
up front okay I think a lot of people
quantify or attach a dollar value to
what they spend on services based on
what they earn at their job and so you
know let's say I earn $200 an hour at my
job and that would I would attach that
to as an answer to your question then it
brings up an interesting question if I
earn more an hour than I get more for $1
and then people who are unless get less
right okay so so I did a calculation in
this book here of the total amount of
hours of attention given to TV and the
total amount of income earned by the
advertising companies and what it works
out to is that people who are watching
TV are earning the advertising companies
20 cents an hour twenty cents basically
that's what their value of attention is
20 cents okay and if you do the same
calculation for other things it can get
a little higher but not much higher the
about the highest against maybe two or
three dollars an hour so that's what
we're giving that's the that's what
other people are monetizing our
attention at that rate so it's really
really cheap it's nowhere near $200 and
so that's the kind of a conundrum it's
like if that's so valuable to us how can
we're giving it away 20 cents an hour
you have to breach the privacy layer to
get there where we wait do we have the
microphone here please said go ahead say
yeah so so the value of speaking to you
for an hour is different than the value
of speaking to your demographic uh-huh
and so there's two ways that's gonna
happen either in a transactional basis
meaning like I want to target you with a
net and this is where we get IA i can
actually reach that privacy barrier
without paying the premium okay all
right good okay so I have time for one
more question answer I know you people
have more but I'm gonna do one more
because I have five minutes or something
is that right so this is also about well
actually that's too complicated so yeah
for in five minutes so I will go for it
okay well okay here's a last chapter in
the book gets really cosmic and Spacey
and talks about what I talked about in
earlier long now talk about this idea of
the holos this kind of super organism
that we're making with seven billion
people connected together and there's
seven billion smartphones into the seven
trillion server computers all connected
into one large something
it's a superorganism machine it I called
holos meaning that there's is this
emergent global something and I think
that a lot of the kind of amazing
miraculous things that we could not that
we could not even division in the past
twenty years I've come about because we
have made tools that allow us to
collaborate in some fashion at a scale
that was never before possible so we
have 1.5 billion people on Facebook then
in some sense is collaborating at a
scale that was simple
unthinkable before and that we're going
to continue to advance that and we'll be
able to do things where we will do
something with having seven billion
people doing something together by all
estimates by the year 2025 every adult
on the planet will have some device 100
percent of them will have a device that
connects and so when we have this this
this huge connection in this ability to
do things like Wikipedia which is simply
impossible in theory there's no
theoretical way it could work and it
does and that's because it's harness
this ability to take a lot of people
around the world and connect them
together in a way that was not possible
before in doing things collaboratively
that we couldn't do and so a lot of the
big I think successes and amazing things
we're going to see in the in the next 20
years are going to be due to the fact
that we're going to be able to harness
our collective and collaboration at
scales in real time that we're not
possible before and so the thing I
become interested in is world government
which nobody thinks is a good idea as
far as I can tell and I'm interested in
how seven billion people connected
together and can in some way steer
themselves can in some way be democratic
how does that even possible
and so I I have really no ideas about
what that mechanisms would look like do
you have this kind of another layer
hierarchy of representations and and
stuff does that does that work at this
scale is there something else do you
have direct voting is is that does that
doesn't even make any sense
and so the question I have because I
don't know any answers in the next three
minutes is does anybody have an idea
about how you would do a democratic
world government with 7 billion people
whoa hey okay wait a minute I'm gonna
answer you somebody wait over here
because I haven't been on this side yet
and I won't include them okay yeah go
ahead yeah that's great question thanks
for asking it I love the idea of two
sort of notions of what we already have
at her disposal crowdfunding and Twitter
this idea of giving a real-time proxy of
part of our power and what would it look
like to have simultaneously a sort of
internal civic crowdfunding mechanism
that worked for the whole world that
worked on a local and a global level and
also where we could give part of our you
know our specific expertise that we
wanted to delegate to somebody so that
system could work in parallel to
something that was not fully direct
democracy it's a balance so somebody
else over there have another I see the
person yes right here with me right
there you go hold it up to your mouth
yeah I actually don't have the mechanism
but I believe that once we see the
larger hole the civilization as the
organism we see homeless as a thing then
then that opens the door for the great
okay you can pass it to the guy right
there yes you there okay even smoking
cute what's this work I think it's a
similar to what he was saying before
there is a concept called the liquid
democracy where by you can give your
vote to someone that you trust but you
can take that vote away immediately and
give it back to someone else so you
don't have to wait for five year cycles
and you can vote on anything so for most
things you don't know anything about you
let someone else vote for you but if
something you care about and you or you
know about steps in you can vote
directly and possibly VI block chain
mechanism but yeah I think what you just
said is a very important element that
would have to be in there another
important element might have been in
some of what you were saying as well is
that we don't want to lose that
principle of federalism where one of the
risks of having a world government is
that you every experiment become so
high-stakes that everything can be lost
if it goes wrong so you really want an
opportunity to experiment at a more
local level and have the successes
ripple up
testing kind of so to speak great so I
just need to conclude to say that those
are what I don't know but the book has a
lot more of what I was certain about and
those kinds of things extended to things
like screening the fact that there would
be more screens in the world flowing
interacting questioning so the last
thing I want to say is is that I think
in the future when we want to have an
answer we ask a machine machines would
give us answers I think what we're going
to be moving to as answers become free
and ubiquitous and very very accurate we
asked Alexa and it gives the right
answer again and again and again again
is is that we're going to start to value
questions more and more that asking a
good question will be what we want
humans to do and what we try to train to
do and that they in the long term or
should at least the near term asking a
good question will be more important
than a good answer so thank you for your
attention
[Applause]
[Music]